controversial take this ranking won't be
accounting for the later seasons of the
show since no good characters were added
and everyone essentially deteriorates
from how horrendous their writing became
or it won't be considering the bad
directions david and dan took the
characters and will mainly be looking at
the best and good qualities our
characters possess also this will be the
most divisive ranking since literally
anyone on this list is probably
someone's favorite so keep in mind this
is my opinion
number 20
rob stark
just because i'm putting rob stark at
number 20 doesn't make him a bad
character that just means there are
dozens of good characters in the show
and cramping them into 20 is difficult
for rob stark i think he doesn't live up
to his full potential on the show
because david and dan didn't give him a
lot of priority as i said in my analysis
on season 2 most of his battle conflicts
fall into the background and his
romantic story with talissa takes center
stage which on its own is fine but
arguably the battle of the 5 king should
be getting more attention i think in
season three we get a much better
balance of the battle in his romance
considering that he marries solis at the
end of season two so we get more
conflict like a lot of discourse amongst
his officers people going against his
orders and him having to execute people
and looking for forgiveness from the
phrase
season 3 rob stark is practically
perfect and i think if he got more of
the spotlight then he'd be higher on my
list
number 19
eddard stark
so there are a few characters on this
list that are only in one season and
it's hard to quantify their placement
because they have a limited amount of
time but from this short time i think
ned stark still cements himself as being
a great character his honorable demeanor
is perfectly contrasted against the
corrupt and slimy members of the small
council through his perspective we see
how cruel the world of game of thrones
is and it makes it equally as tragic
when that world swallows him whole and
takes his life i also love the critical
choice he has to make to leave behind
his perfect life in winterfell with his
family to try and save his best friend
robert since she just found out that jon
aaron was killed it imbues his character
with an engaging objective and we
instantly latch onto him as we travel
through king's landing which is why it's
so heartbreaking when he dies since we
lost our main pov protagonist the main
reason he hasn't hired is because of the
unfortunate one season limit
number 18 catelynn stark
it may seem a bit controversial to be
putting catelyn over ned and rob but i
think she's much more of a complex
character she's generally submerged in
internal conflict that makes her feel
like one of the most fully realized
characters so many issues bubbling under
the surface like her hatred towards jon
snow and how that illustrates her
emphasis on family and choosing to let
jamie go for the long shot of getting
her daughters back all of her major
decisions drastically change the story
and they are all justified from her own
perspective of a loving mother there's
also so much nuance in her performance
any scene in which michelle farley has
some great material to sink her teeth
into she knocks it out of the park in
essence that's why the red wedding is so
damn impactful the acting alone is a
killer performance that leaves everyone
speechless and that's not even
mentioning some of her more low-key
scenes like her confession of not being
able to love jon snow after promising
she try her best the emotional depth of
catelyn is crazy and i genuinely don't
know why people dislike her although
personally i wouldn't put her much
higher because i think she shines in one
area while other characters are like
multifaceted tools with so many great
aspects to be enjoyed
number 17
stannis baratheon
now relax i know it's a crime to some of
you that i'm putting the almighty
standards stannis the goddamn mantis at
number 17 but personally i prefer the
more lively characters because stannis
most of the time is brooding and to me
that can become a bit dull at times
however sanderson season 2 was
practically perfect the cold calculating
general driven by a destiny that he holy
believes in makes for an engaging
character even when stannis is losing
he's still getting good dialogue scenes
where he's questioning melisandre and
whether he's truly worthy the angel and
devil of davos and melisandre pulling
stannis in differing directions also
makes her an outstanding dynamic from
how much conflict is being thrown around
and stannis having to constantly make
hard choices makes every scene even more
tense he's also constantly permeating a
badass demeanor and even when he's in a
losing scenario he still comes across as
a hero i fully respect stannis and if
season 3 4 and 5 were able to reach the
highs of season 2 for him as a character
i would easily place him in my top 10.
number 16. robert baratheon
i love how bobby v can easily snatch a
spot on my list with having such a small
amount of screen time the drunken meme
dad bod aura bobby b is unmatched by any
character in game of thrones i would
drop anything if this god of a human
descended down upon my plane of
existence and asked to come chill with
him and not only is robert baratheon a
gem of comedy and memes he's also a
character with a shocking amount of
depth due to the amount of history that
is tied to him
robert can just be telling war stories
for an entire episode and i'd be
perfectly satisfied on top of his
relationship dynamic was cersei and how
tragic it was for her that robert's lust
for lyanna ruined everything an overall
great character study of a warrior way
past their prime and seeing what happens
to a character like that as they
brutally self-destruct with rampant
usage of alcohol [ __ ] and memes
number 15
brawn
braun is an interesting case because he
initially started out number 11 on my
list and i've been slowly lowering him
and that's because in comparison to most
of the other characters ahead of him
he's not as complex brawn is a simple
character who has very clear and cut
objectives and ideals that obviously
doesn't make him bad but in comparison
to other colorful characters like varys
and littlefinger he can't compete in my
opinion however his capabilities for
being an amazing duo partner to tyrion
and jaime and how much humor pours out
between them makes him an extremely fun
character so much of game of thrones
best humor comes from brawn or from him
egging on tearing and messing with him
every one of his scenes in the first few
seasons are practically perfect for what
they are fun comedic relief that
breathes fresh air into the dark world
of game of thrones and he also doesn't
only add humor but he injects a
surprising amount of wisdom from his
extensive experience as a sellsword
along with offering an interesting
juxtaposition of someone who fights
without honor clashing with people who
do it makes almost every encounter he
has with other characters pretty unique
number 14
oberyn martell
this is so sad i would absolutely love
to put obern much higher but since he's
only in season 4
i can't really put him that high that
being said for the few scenes he does
have they are all easily asked here from
his perfect introduction setting up his
relationship to the lannisters how
badass he is and him still respecting
tyrion while he goes on in detail about
how much he lows his house to the
magnificent monologue he gives tyrion in
his crazy fight that ends in utter
tragedy that leaves everyone in
crippling shock this is a character that
quickly comes in and leaves an
outstanding impression for the little
amount of screen time he had he's
quick-witted and charming and even over
martel can rival time when lannister in
a dialogue scene the sinister smiles
they give each other is cute as hell
oberyn is arguably the most likable
character in the show and it's a crime
that george rr martin killed him so
early it's a shame that we're getting
numerous spin-off shows from game of
thrones but we aren't getting an oberon
spin-off come on
pedro is selling his prime
number 13. ramsay bolton his
unpredictable nature makes him extremely
menacing and the amount of fury strikes
into his neighboring characters makes us
shudder in terror iwan rion does a
perfect job encapsulating ramsay for how
much of a twisted psychopath he is
the only reason i wouldn't put him a bit
higher is because the show really delves
into why ramsay turned out to be so
crazy we have one scene where he talks
about his mother briefly and up until
season six where his position is
challenged by ruse's new son we never
really get any conflicts between him and
ruse so it's a bit of a mystery why
ramsay's such a disturbed character
although to a degree it's fun to imagine
how dark his backstory is and the
vagueness behind it can aid him in a way
just in comparison to a fully fleshed
out villain like joffrey i would put
ramsay under him but i do think ewon
does some amazing legwork in his
performance to make ramsey such a crazy
villain and that paired with george rr
martin's diabolical writing it makes for
a great duo of a character
number 12
peter baelish the essence of what made
season 1 of game of thrones so great and
seasons 2 3 and 4 for that matter the
political and canifical nature of
littlefinger is very alluring and
entrancing we're always wondering and
theorizing what he's up to and trying to
figure out what his motives are is so
much fun the twist of him lying to ned
throughout season one imbues every later
scene with littlefinger with an essence
of doubt because we are always unsure of
whether he's lying or telling the truth
he's also a unique villain in that he's
always in the background manipulating
his story into different directions from
being the person that starts the war
between the lannisters and the starks to
killing lysa aaron and successfully
taking control of the veil also i think
the secret sauce of littlefinger is
aiden gillen's incredible rasping
grating voice it gives his character a
more creepy and unsettling demeanor and
it always sounds like he's 10 steps
ahead of everyone the amount of
confidence exuding from peter is
honestly sexy and i can't keep my eyes
off him whenever he's in the room
number 11
varus
so varys is very similar to littlefinger
in that they are both scheming
mysterious people who work behind the
scenes to achieve their own objective
the main difference is that varys is the
good guy or at least in the show the
primary reason i put him over
littlefinger is that his duo with tyrion
offers more in value than peter's duo
with sansa tyrion and varys's dialogue
scenes offer up some magnificent lines
and are a clear highlight in the first
few seasons littlefinger peaks higher
than varys in some iconic moments but
varys has a more consistent presence
since littlefinger is also traveling a
lot and doing things in the background
from that alone i think varus has more
to offer and his backstory is also more
intriguing because not only did a weird
pedo cut off his privates for fun but
there's also a magical aspect tied to it
in that when his privates were thrown
into the fire a voice called out thus
feeling varus's hatred towards magic and
making him a more detailed character
that and also the balance of sinisterism
and friendliness within varys makes him
even more curious as we try to figure
out what angle he's playing at his
ability to flip between those two states
reminds us that he's still a force to be
reckoned with and makes me respect him
even more
number 10
olenna tyrell
you may think i'm crazy for putting
olenna tyrell over so many iconic
characters but hear me out this is a
character that is old and is physically
not intimidating but she is still able
to be one of the biggest badasses in
game of thrones she's written with a
ferocious temperament and roasts
everyone she comes across not only is
her fierce and funny dialogue riveting
she's also a really smart character with
heaps of wisdom thanks to how much
experience she's gone through you may
think that elena talking about potential
love interest would be boring but from
elena's fun perspective of knocking down
and dismantling people with her quick
wit makes the dialogue significantly
better and this applies to every
dialogue scene she's in the only time
that she is matched is by tywin
lannister and even that scene was like a
fun fight where the future of their
houses were at stake and as a side point
i'm not accounting for the later seasons
but elena is really one of the only
characters that had a great scene which
was her confession to jaime that she
killed joffrey so not even david and dan
can ruin olenna
number 9
joffrey baratheon i feel like most
people would probably say that joffrey
is the best villain in the show but i
would argue that there's another main
villain that's even better joffrey on
his own is such an interesting case of
what if a child grows up into being the
worst human being possible that by
itself is a great what if scenario
character study but also pairing that
scenario with him becoming the king is a
jackpot idea it gives an evil character
unlimited power and plays into the
unpredictable menacing nature of a good
villain because he can literally do
anything listening to someone playing a
song adios tongue hanging out with sansa
time to shake up our relationship with a
nice crossbow joffrey's spontaneous
attitude and doing insane things on the
fly makes him an infectious villain to
watch and it's all grounded because this
is a spoiled child with an obscene
amount of power since joffrey's
backstory is more cemented and fully
realized in comparison to ramsay it
makes his clash with family members even
more tense and exciting like tywin
lannister being one of the best and
tyrion slapping him around never gets
old
number eight
daenerys targaryen
dany isn't in the top five what
but supercut's delight she's a main
character yes but for most of daenerys's
scenes she's generally dealing with the
same conflict tied to her being a
conqueror and that can get repetitive
when looking at her entire run however
is her conqueror and upbringing
character arc bad
no not by any means and it's extremely
entertaining her turn from being
suppressed and a scared child to a
raging leader with heaps of power is a
magnificent joy ride one of the most
iconic set-pieces in the whole show is
danny accumulating the unsullied and
from then on her story is intensely
riveting as she rolls through cities and
we get dopamine hit after dopamine hits
also in the rare cases where her
battle-hardened facade is peeled back in
a more dramatic scene like locking away
her dragons and ser jorah's betrayal i
think it offers a much-needed dose of
vulnerability although the most
interesting part of her entire arc to me
and concept is the mad queen arc but i
can't take that into account because it
was butchered later on so naturally i'll
put her under the other main characters
a bit because of the unfortunate
circumstance of one of the meatiest
parts of her story taking place during
season eight and seven and it also takes
a couple seasons for her character to
really pop off in comparison to tyrion
as an example who is amazing right out
of the gate
number seven
sandor clegane sandra clegane isn't just
a one trick funny dude who roasts people
left and right but he has a lot of
trauma under his heart exterior shell
and once you get to know him the hound
evolves into a more friendly puppy this
deconstruction is perfectly showcased
between the pairing of arya and the
hounds and their dialogue alone makes me
love him to death and this
deconstruction works both ways and that
the hound also challenges some of arya's
ideals and outlooks like what makes a
good warrior and the harsh reality of
the worlds he becomes her guardian and
this deserter turned father is one of my
favorite character arcs in the show and
i want to go back to him roasting people
because he has a miraculous town of
utterly disintegrating people with just
his usage of words it makes him even
more likeable when he's out here rolling
characters since he has no fear of death
but fire that's scary as hell and it's
also ironic that this brood of a
character is so scared of it it makes
his character even more vulnerable and
real not just an unstoppable force
number 6
jamie lannister
this man is at the center stage of one
of the best scenes in the whole show
where it's just a monologue about him
revealing the truth of the mad king and
exposing how being a knight isn't black
and white and is instead morally
complicated and throughout it's so
entrancing because we're impacting the
entirety to what makes this character
operate everything is spilling out and
it's beautiful i am describing one scene
out of a plethora but this is the magnum
opus that makes us love jaime as a
character before he came across as an
arrogant brat who thought he was always
in the right however through this
journey with brienne he learns what it
takes to be an upstanding knight george
r martin turns a seemingly irredeemable
killing machine into one of the most
relatable characters that feat alone is
some outstanding writing and jaime is
such a good character that he even
survives in later seasons until
obviously the one catastrophic line that
ruins his character obviously though i'm
not taking that into account the only
reason why i wouldn't put him higher on
my list was because he was kind of tied
to a post for a whole season and even
then there were still a couple great
dialogue scenes while he was a prisoner
number five arya stark
we made it to the top five and arya is
easily deserving i love her adventurous
and courageous attitude which makes her
seem even stronger when in the face of
death it's ironic how much bravery she
has given her young age which makes her
even more commendable also the overall
concept of a highborne lady wanting to
become a brilliant warrior is inherently
really intriguing and i think they fully
execute on that fun premise by her
joining the faceless assassins and also
training under syria pharrell her slowly
becoming more and more powerful over the
course of the series gives us a fun
progression and whenever she shows off
her new abilities and does something for
the first time we become enthralled that
and two of her seasons are spent hanging
out with the hound so she really has no
downtime and before that she had a
rollercoaster of a ride through king's
landing for season 1 in season 2 she
hung out with tywin most characters at
some point have a doll section in their
story but arya's storyline is always
delightful
number 4
cersei lannister
now this isn't the best villain that is
still yet to come cersei to me is a bit
more of a protagonist who occasionally
clashes with our main heroes on the
outside she may come across as hostile
however on the inside she's a loving
mother who will do anything for her own
children similar to catelyn although
cersei doesn't have a lot of honor to
hold her back this leads her to be more
vicious and seeing the link she goes to
for her children is crazy lena hidi also
thoroughly elevates the character with
her superb acting and seeing her hit her
extremes is breathtaking her singular
scene of the death of joffrey was
amazing and i'm really surprised she
didn't win any emmys for the entirety of
her run at cersei not only is she great
on her own but she also shines in
numerous character pairings whether
she's clashing with bobby b and ned
having chill talks with tyrion that
exposes her backstory her loving jaime
her desperately trying to impress her
father and rolling any other
miscellaneous character that crosses her
path
number 3
jon snow
going into this list i was going to
shaft jon because of how much the later
seasons made me hate him but after
rewatching some of the earlier seasons
i've come to like him a lot more again
and was reminded about how he was
actually a great character through the
first half of the show we don't just
have the same repetitive dialogue but a
character that's drowning in so much
conflict that tears him apart like his
constant state of friction with catelyn
him kind of being misled into thinking
the night's watch was a great place and
realizing everyone there are criminals
changing his entire outlook on life when
joining the free folk and balancing
helping them while simultaneously trying
to protect his brothers from getting
killed by the free folk jon snow changes
significantly throughout his journey
like he's doing 180s in almost every
season even through all this change dawn
is still anchored down by a strong
honorable core that is inherited from
ned so he's realistic while also having
a dynamic and thrilling story not to
mention that he led the episode the
watchers on the wall which is by far the
best episode in the show where jon is an
almighty warrior so not only is his
character development really good he's
also a really good fighter and his fight
scenes are really fun number two
tywin lannister
this is my list and i absolutely adore
tywin i hope you're proud of me for
refraining from putting him at number
one
charles dance perfectly sinks into the
character of tywin his voice is like
smooth jazz
that melts my insides the way he deals
with characters and destroys people in
such an easy manner makes me gush with
joy the scene in which he demolishes
joffrey by sending him to bed shows how
much of an alpha god he is tywin is the
best villain in the show not because of
his unpredictable or scary manner but
because of how much power the single man
has and from that power he literally has
the confidence of a lion just by staring
at you his eyes turn into daggers and a
single frown from this legend would be
like on the other end of a nuclear
explosion unlike some of the other
villains talwin has better dynamics with
other characters given that he isn't
flat out crazy joffrey and ramsey are
great on their own but generally they
close themselves off from getting too
close to anyone tywin on the other hand
is a father and he has to control his
children and that brings out a lot of
good dynamics and the best one is
definitely tyrion his hatred towards
tyrion slowly gets more and more
detailed until it explodes in season 4
with an ultimate showdown between them
this makes all of their interactions
engaging as hell and that is just one
dynamic out of a handful taiwan is bae
and it saddens me when i see lis eating
talent out of the top 10 in even 20.
number one
tyrion lannister
if you watch my videos this shouldn't be
that surprising because generally i gush
about how much i like him in season one
through four now if i was including the
entire show then i don't even know if
tyrion would make it onto my list from
how terribly stupid he became but hey
we're not looking at the bad baby we
gotta give our main characters a chance
so characters exclusive to the first few
seasons don't sweep the entire list
tyrion is the perfect storm of a
character he's funny smart brave
charismatic and despite having some of
these seemingly perfect characteristics
he still deals with a lot of conflict
and that he's always looked down on for
being a dwarf he's constantly fighting a
never-ending uphill battle and this
endless chain of conflict makes us love
him we get attached to characters who
are constantly at odds and are still
able to come out on top in large part
this is a thank you to him being a
lannister and that title also gives him
a massive confidence boost in scenes
where most people would be scared he's
still wittily talking his way out of
dangerous scenarios the ability to use
your words as a form of conflict
resolution is refreshing in a world
where so much conflict is resolved with
the swing of a sword tyrion doesn't need
one and that aspect makes him courageous
seeing him in any scene where he's being
challenged instantly makes it
entertaining because we are dying to see
how he outsmarts his opponents and even
when everyone is against him he is still
able to find a way to come out on top
like his outstanding trial by combat
speech i'm trying not to exceed that big
of a time limit for each of these
rankings but i could honestly go on for
a while about why tearing is the best
maybe i should just make it its own
video at this rate overall though his
journey throughout king's landing is
utterly riveting and to me he's the most
charming and likable character that i
love to watch any scene with tyrion is
amazing
i would go into honorable mentions to
argue why i didn't put some characters
on this list like theon and sansa being
two big ones but i think i'll delegate
that discussion to a pinned comment in
the comment section so if you're curious
you can look into that so you don't have
to sit through five minutes of me
defending myself regardless though thank
you for watching and let me know who
your favorite characters are down below